at least three people are dead after  severe weather swept across the Upper  Midwest and Canada Friday when gusts of  more than 60 miles per hour sent this  sky crane spinning in Toronto  it's the latest bout of severe storms  after a quiet start to the spring oh my  god  high winds toppled trees peeled back  rooftops and sent boxes flying across an  airport runway the Great Lakes region  under an aerial assault for much of  Friday with deadly results a man was  killed northwest of Detroit  when part of a tree snapped and fell on  him while he was working in a yard who  would ever thought I mean we all have  the big trees in the art no one would  have ever thought that it was very sad  very sad a man in Canada died after  witnesses saw him trying to clear downed  wires from a roadway while another was  killed by a falling tree nearly half a  million customers in the u.s. from the  Great Lakes to New England lost power  another 100,000 in Canada were blocked  out as well